هنا في شمال قطاع غزه تزداد معاناه
المواطنين والنازحين مع اجداد الحرب
والحصار وايضا منع الاحتلال دخول
المساعدات حتى اللحظه الى مناطق الشمال
هنا وايضا معاناه دخول مياه الصرف الصحي
ومياه الامطار هنا على النازحين داخل
مستشفى اليمن السعيد مما ادى الى تدهور
الوضع البيئي والوضع الصحي ايضا وعدم توفر
الطعام ل ين والمواطنين وايضا شح المواد
الغذائيه في الاسواق هنا في شمال قطاع غزه
كما نشاهد هنا كيف الوضع المعيشي هنا
للمواطنين ونازحين ايضا الوضع بحكي عن
حاله
اولا المجاري ثانيا
الامطار ثالثا الوضع اللي احنا عايشينه
قله مواد غذائيه فقر ولا في مواد تنظيف
ولا في غذاء لا بقوللك اليوم الوم بده
يعبر علينا الاحتلال مسكر علينا كل
المعابر ما حد فيش شي عدي علينا من اي
مساعدات لا صحيه ولا غذائيه هذا اول شيء
بعدين شوف وضعنا شوف حالنا بنشرب الميه
اللي بنجلي
فيها المي اللي بنجلي منها وبنغسل منها
احنا بنشرب منها نفس السطل اللي بنتلي ل
للجال الله يعزك وللحمام وللضوء للغسيل
بنشرب منه احنا فيش مي صالحه للشرب فيش مي
صالحه للشرب البير شغلوه الحيوانات والبني
ادمين وال والمجاري وكل بيشرب من مين من
البير اللي بيشغلو نا احنا بنطالب كل
الدول وكل امه محمد وكل الاسلام وكل
الاجانب وكل الناس اللي بهمها وضع فلسطين
تقف معنا مئات العائلات تعيش في هذا
المكان هذا المكان الذي لا يصلح نهائيا
للسكن لكن بسبب الظروف وبسبب عدم توفر اي
ماوى لهذه العائلات لجوا لهذا المكان طبعا
هنا دخلت مياه الامطار ومياه الصرف الصحي
على هذه العائلات مما فاقم معاناه
العائلات هنا داخل هذا المكان هذا الطفل
لته سبعاوي 29 اسبوع بشربه قاعد حليب بميه
ساقعه الولد نمت فيه ثلاث ايام في مستشفى
كمال عدوان ما فيش ادويه معناش مصاري نجيب
له ادويه صرت اشحد من الناس من يسقيه ند
في الدواء اشربه اللي يجيب لي بالسرنجه
واللي يقول لي ما عنديش بتين احنا من
الجوع مش لاقين احنا ناكل مش لاقين نشرب
انا كنت يعني يعني قاعده عمال بقول للراجل
يا عم اذا عند خبز جيب لنا كو يا عم
الطحين 12 شيكل رطل الطحين 70 شيكل قسما
بالله ما معي مصار اروح اشتري له بمبز
نفسي اصح لي صح نكسر طعميه للولد جينا
هونه المكان اللي موجودين احنا فيه حاليا
يعتبر مقبره جماعيه مش ماوى ل للناس هنا
عندك الصرف الصحي طف يعني علينا فات للغرف
عندك الامراض انتشرت بين الاطفال بين
الكبار الوضع ماساوي لاقصى درجه يعني ايش
بدي اقوللك انت شايف الصوره انا يعني يعني
بتعبر اكثر من الكلام هذذه بعد صرف صحي
هذا والله الموجود وانت بتعرف ايش قديش
الغلاء المعيشي اللي احنا
فيه بيحكوا انه في مساعدات ما شفنا لحتى
الان ولا شي في شي فات علينا احنا الطحين
بنشتري الرطل ب 40 و 50 شيكل وب 70 شيكل
رطل الطحين يعني الاطفال ها اللي انت
شايفها ها يعني من من يوم ما اجت تقريبا
ما حد غير اواعي المعاناه تلاحق النازحين
هنا في كل مكان حتى في مراكز الايواء
الذين اتخذوها ماوى لهم الا ان مياه الصرف
الصحي ومياه الامطار تح في كل مكان وايضا
تكدس النفايات في مراكز الاواء وانتشار
الوباء بين المواطنين وبين الاطفال وبين
النساء في هذه الاماكن انس الشريف الجزيره
شمال
غزه